[Musique]
et
ça vient
côte de theux
bonjour les laines et l'eau
[Musique]
mich en train de faire un poker avec ce
monsieur là avec sa tête il est bon il
est bon il est bon il me reste plus rien
mais il est bon dans le drame avec mamie
qui a coté olalalala
4 easter il est trop chaude afin qu'un
[Musique]
bon les amis là je sors de tpm pêcher
avec le renne du père noël est pas loin
visiblement n'oubliez pas si vous êtes
gentils d'aller voir inside ont mis ma
dernière vidéo jour supplie jeunes live
d'abonnement qui me désespère j'adore le
pen
[Musique]
regarde et au mode elle soutient thomas
ouais tu me dit audacieux c'est quoi ton
costume d'halloween cette année un goût
classique je prends le sol est donc ce
que les biens peur un classique outfit à
voter die donc petites baskets petit
pantalon en velours ceinture petites
chemises en soie des petits colis voilà
voilà les missions définies
j'espère que ça vous a plu je vous dis à
demain
[Musique]